well we are getting our first criminal
charges in the Trump Russia
investigation from special prosecutor
Robert Muller remember the charges that
so many said we would never get we would
never hear about it was a nothing
burglar and of course many of them will
still say that even after I explained to
you today what these charges are it is
former campaign chairman and campaign
manager Paul Manafort who has been
indicted on 12 criminal charges over the
weekend we learned that charges were
upcoming but we didn't know who were
they against and what were the charges
well now we know a lot of that Paul mana
Ford of course was under investigation
for everything between I don't know
federal tax law violations money
laundering lack of disclosure of foreign
lobbying money and indeed 12 counts
conspiracy against the United States
conspiracy to launder money being an
unregistered agent of a foreign
principle false and misleading foreign
agents Registration Act statements false
statements to investigators and seven
counts of failing to file reports of
foreign bank and financial accounts now
the top candidates for me and I'm not
patting myself on the back in any way I
was I was talking about manna fort and
Flynn and Kushner and it happened to be
one of those three and we'll see who
else ultimately Falls but not a surprise
Paul Manafort ordered to turn himself in
and he is not the only person indicted
along with manna fort we saw the
indictment of former business associate
of Paul Manafort
Rick Gates who is also wrapped up in
this and we have learned the specific
charges CNN is also reporting that there
may be further indictments today and my
expectation when I heard about this on I
think it was Friday that it broke was
the Trump campaign is going to continue
distancing not only from whoever it is
that's indicted and in this case it is
Paul manna Ford they are also going to
say well this doesn't lead back to Trump
we'll deal with that second part in a
moment but I'll remind you the Trump
campaign has been trying to distance
from Paul Manafort for a while because
it's been clear for some time that he
was at the top of the list manna fort
was not only at the top of my list he
was at the top of the obvious list of
who
the first indictments might be against
remember Sean Spicer trying to play it
very coy like it's not even really sure
what this guy Paul Manafort did he was
with us so briefly general Flynn but
again I write it and I'm not aware of
any at this time but even general Flynn
was with a volunteer of the campaign and
then obviously there's been discussion
of Paul Manafort who played a very
limited role for a very limited amount
of time but beyond hey John Johnson one
can you can you stop interrupting other
people's questions okay Jonathan
somebody your questions are getting in
the way of my completely defenseless
apologia for the involvement of Paul
manna forth in our campaign manka fort
sorry who oh man afford yeah we barely
saw the guy I don't even really know who
he was he must have been back with the
interns and the key thing to think about
is the denials from people on both the
left and right for different reasons
about Trump Russia for months
can we trust a word those people say
because remember they were all saying
nothing's going to happen there's not
going to be any official investigation
well we've got three investigations
there's not going to be any special
prosecutor well we've got special
prosecutor Robert Moeller the Russia
dossier is completely faking bogus well
it's real it was presented to Trump and
Obama and more and more elements of that
dossier have been confirmed to be true
we aren't ever going to get charges it's
going to disappear but here we are in
October almost November of 2017 getting
our first charges it's fake news there's
no evidence for anything forget about it
what happened to that and what's
happening is that they're moving the
goal posts that is the important thing
to keep in mind the White House is
already saying the charges don't relate
to Russia and the charges don't relate
to Trump they were merely financial
things that manna fort was involved in
before he was part of the campaign which
isn't true the indictment contains dates
that were while and after manna fort was
directly involved with the Trump
campaign Trump taking to Twitter
immediately this morning after the
announcement of these indictments saying
sorry but this is years ago before Paul
Manafort was part of the Trump campaign
but why aren't crooked Hillary and the
Democrats the folk
going on to say also there is no
collusion now of course this isn't true
again charges against man afford include
actions taken during the time man afford
and gates were working for the campaign
and it's important to focus on Rick
gates as well he continued to work for
the Trump campaign and even the
inaugural committee after Paul Manafort
disappeared it's important to note that
gates visited the White House multiple
times this year 2017 and the goal posts
keep moving if there are charges that
are related to the campaign eventually
we'll hear from the Trump campaign that
Trump had no idea and that there has
been no intent shown on the behalf of
Donald Trump to collude with Russia or
be involved with Russia or whatever no
matter what they are going to move the
goal posts always one step ahead of
where the investigation is and that's
why you need to focus here no matter how
minor the charges seem no matter how
disconnected and the charges aren't
minor no matter how disconnected the
charges seem from Donald Trump remember
that with Watergate and Richard Nixon it
was nearly two years between the first
charges and the eventual resignation of
President Richard Nixon early charges
are early because they're often the
easiest charges to prosecute right the
clearest cases and some of the lower
people on the totem pole
that you can maybe get to flip and
cooperate and inform on the really big
dogs remember Sammy the bull Gravano who
admitted to killing more than a dozen
people I think it was close to 20 people
that he admitted to having killed he got
five years because he cooperated and
flipped and was able to provide evidence
on the big dogs so doing this early for
Robert Moeller and his investigation
puts these early indict E's
is that the word indictees and I tease
and I tease I think it would be it puts
them in the position of maybe being able
to provide evidence for the eventual
indictment and prosecution of countless
others manna forts involvement is a link
between Trump and Russia that is his
background his history is a decade I
don't know how many years of making big
bucks lobbying for foreign
countries including Russia and his
involvement in the Trump campaign is a
connection between Donald Trump and
Russia he's the connection okay so don't
be bamboozled the way Trump has so often
done the fact that there are charges is
the news not whether they directly link
Trump to action with Russia and number
two does this shed new light on the
apoplexy and fever with which Trump and
right-wing media have been pushing the
JFK files stuff and how they've been
pushing the Hillary uranium stuff and
the DNC wanted the Russia dossier the
timing probably wasn't a coincidence it
is very likely that the right-wing media
machine and the Trump machine had a
sense that this was coming and they
started the distract Athan because while
of a sudden are all the tweets about
Hillary and the Dutch Russian dossier
exploding we have Devon Nunez saying
there's a new investigation into
Hillary's email it's all very odd but
it's par for the course with these
clowns in the White House I looked at
foxnews.com over the weekend when the
charges news of the charges had broken
but not specifically that it was mana
Ford or what the 12 counts were nothing
on the home page of Fox news.com about
it seven or eight different links to
articles about Hillary Clinton so what
will Trump's eventual reaction be if
this continues to build we got the bad
guys I barely knew them let's get rid of
Muller right now and by the way too we
also learned today that on October 5th
or 3rd I believe it was George
papadopolis pled guilty to lying to the
FBI as part of the Trump Russia
investigation Papadopoulos was I believe
a foreign policy adviser to trump who
Trump said is a good guy that is an
indictment with a direct connection to
the campaign and Trump okay so we have
not only indictments but also guilty
pleas already stemming from this
investigation let's now go to the
reaction from the trumpets the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership